a lughead I did call you a lug head hi
everyone welcome back to Knievel I was
just calling my clog head in what's sure
to be an eventful episode better but I'm
not gonna spoil anything but veterans of
the game might know I'm talking about
[Music]
but first we're gonna do a housekeeping
item that a bunch of people have been
reminding us - I keep getting told in
the comments every episode girl don't
you forget about that fire extinguisher
yes I left it in the first metal
detector I did tour the army base yeah
we won't need it anytime soon but it's
probably best to get it now okay while
we're thinking of it as then the rest of
the episode will probably be straight
forward okay so I'm gonna go do that now
I'll go - we're doing this thing again
this camera angle because the ratio the
game you're not really seeing less you
loved it it's better it's just better
there's some people in the YouTube
comments I prefer the old way but they
probably like you small yeah what if I
was big I don't wanna hear a camera was
gone all right let's go okay yeah yeah
oh I also found this look at this
there's a little secret bullies and you
found it or are you ready to YouTube
commented I found it while I was waiting
for you I was running around like this
thank you I found it on my own
yeah I know you did okay it's 4:45 on a
Thursday in Philadelphia Pennsylvania
where it's Wednesday also I screw up a
lot of that did I go down there I've
been down there right that's where you
came from yeah oh yeah I really wanna go
sorry I got confused there's nothing
else in this room right I think you
clean it okay so the first thing we're
gonna do just backtrack almost to the
beginning of the game is where the metal
detector is get the metal detector
don't remember how to be honest figured
out we got the map I'm afraid of seeing
Wesker again like I was real meaning
remember how many times you hit
me oh yeah he just think the [ __ ] I do
like one would have proven his point but
he just kept punching me and like
throwing me around if I was him I'd have
a bone to pick with the Knievel crew as
well kill him in a volcano we've really
we [ __ ] up Wesker a few times it's one
of the creepy twins he's got a sniper
rifle in a tiny room whoa I'm amazing
okay it's both action wait did you get
shot or not I think one bullet out of 70
Hitler I'm fine it's just a scratch just
a flesh wound it's the 50 caliber
scratch no I wasn't afraid to kill I
know probably shot seven seven too I
don't know little about guns
oh can I have a check smacks peace yes I
thought he was dead
she took her clothes off it's on the bed
that's when did all this happen this is
that other room where you first got the
music please right from is this the
secret door so they could kiss each
other
this must be Oh
what's going on
[Music]
wait a second what just happened
is so there never was an Alexia
they're both mean he thinks he's two
people okay
that's it here the self-destruct system
has been freaked he's trying to blow us
up along with the entire facility come
on we gotta get to that Airport right
yeah actually now that I think we might
not be able to do the fire extinguisher
yet uh is this timed no I'm still hurry
up in keeping with the narrative let me
just finish checking his room so he like
she like removed her dress and then was
like so he was still in like a Lexia
mindset but saw himself in the mirror
also he sounded like a [ __ ] like
orangutan when he jumped at you how did
they do the video of them like almost
making out then was that like the video
was from back in the day there was an
election at one point and there still
could be but the one that just the one
that's been haranguing you has been
Alfred Wow Alfred that ice is it Alfred
Alexia I think this is the way to leave
[Music]
there were bats weren't there
people also pointed out that if you walk
bats won't attack you no way why didn't
we talk about this well I'm not sure
because the same thing happened with the
crows in the first game that door goes
it's a good question alright so I'm
leaving this facility I'll make a seal
that what's happening yeah
was there anything out here they need to
remember I feel like I should be a bit
more prepared for death okay just uh
crossbow on him get rid of these 30 yeah
well people so people are point out
crossbows are more effective against
Manders two niches and they also stagger
them more handguns are better for Oh
normal so should I run and then hit him
yeah probably he looks like he's in
striking range oh that's unfortunate all
right this isn't going well
whoa I think he just crushed my baby
skull okay actually I didn't go well
next try just next time we could
probably just run because I don't think
you're coming back here off the top my
head you might be man I have to do this
that's alright skip it
sorry I like we embrace all the
commenters advice last episode you just
[ __ ] killed everything
it was really fun it's more fun to kill
everything and I felt like I was being
too much of a wiener where I was like
constantly getting hurt
to save like five bullets but it's like
I have no health now at least I think
you're currently I'm on fine and I have
to do what touch bad maybe we meet each
other's breasts penny goodbye so soon
for the pride of the Ashford are you
though watches again it's
[Music]
it is what it is what's going on Steve
so many bullets and it got her in the
eye it looked like after her but then
she's her eyes are fine are you okay
I'm flying it's just a scratch steve is
actually Chris Redfield
it's like a kdrama everybody somebody
I'm fine just I mean hot girl alright
but pay attention to the noise master
this was so confusing to me
wait a second what just happened
so there never was an Alexia after all
you mean he thinks he's two people okay
that's it let's get out of here all
right
destruct system has that freak he's
trying to blow us up along with the
entire facility come on we got to get to
that Airport right can I have this water
that's why I thought it was just a
stupid waiter I appreciate it but I I
mean yes a glass is better but box is
better than bottled yeah true that will
like actually like decompose and less
than I eat plastic though you do know
you'd be surprised like you probably do
because plastic is now in our fish
because we've polluted the water so much
but not like you eat bottles of plastic
and like [ __ ] out fertilizer you
probably do [ __ ] out fertilizer but you
don't eat plastic
yeah isn't fertilizer specifically [ __ ]
um it can be not all [ __ ] is fertilizer
right but it is an all fertilizer [ __ ]
at some point um yes maybe I don't know
I think I should know more about it can
be like it could also be like [ __ ]
it could also be like decomposed stuff
like fruit yeah compost nice nice yeah
this is all tactful I didn't get hurt
though I don't see how you're supposed
to kill those things with such little
space like there's no there's nowhere to
run
yeah controls were not in the early game
strong suit all right so oh [ __ ] I
forgot you got sighs I got a little slap
there tap cool
slapping pickles how am i doing not
great
dump some stuff off that's a good idea
because I have s so what do you mean
let's see I have all I have all three
don't I yeah um that's pretty big deal
so I well yeah you could take him though
unless you're gonna come back here
before you go I don't know am i yeah
yeah let's to go do the fire
extinguisher come back and put it in
here okay so we're gonna do the fire
extinguisher first yeah is that really
designer the episode should be pretty
action-packed okay so I'm gonna leave
them right yeah and we're going to the
fire extinguisher is that alarm gonna be
off going off the whole time I think so
yeah I couldn't move it's really
annoying
Kevin I hear you're chewing which isn't
really like Colleen hey how do you feel
about onomatopoeia people who watch this
have been with us since the beginning
will know that I have gotten more
patient what if I just make the word
like the noise is like choo choo choo
that's fine yeah that's one stinking
we better get out of here too right
let's go
where'd you eat a crossbow okay yeah
what we'll do the fighting for another
time so we're not doing it oh is this
the boss I there is an item box before
that [ __ ] oh you need the proofs [ __ ]
now you got to go back yeah you gotta
get some stuff in the data box we'll do
that thank you thank you so much not to
be rude but like why can't I just do the
fire extinguisher right now like why
can't I I guess there's nothing to stop
you but this stuff is just annoying yeah
but yeah if I get really far away it
probably is fine right I don't think
this game is that sophisticated Oh we'll
let me it won't let me so go back to the
item box how big of a deal is this fire
extinguisher because I'm actually
starting to get worried that we can't do
it oh you can you you come back you say
oh wait I don't know you you just get
the proofs
you don't need healing items yet there's
gonna be another thing before yeah but
if this plays self-destruct it gets the
fire extinguishers knock it off
then even if I restore this episode I
can't fix this because I've set certain
things in motion this is a really
interesting thing that I've done here
like I hope this isn't like yeah - okay
you like where yeah I put one in the
Navy one right yeah like I hope this
isn't the kind of thing we're like I've
basically started to save that I can't
finish the game on because I know you
can do that in this game where I'm with
you but I think you're I think you're
worrying too much
well we're gonna find out people people
in the comments would have known if we
went too far if they wouldn't have been
saying remember to get that I mean they
did say that
and like now essentially just so I'm
gonna shush you stop worrying
you're stressing me out and it's my job
to keep optimism popular you're sorry
what's getting anxious okay fair enough
but besides you have a shame you
couldn't say doing separate saves you'll
be fine you did another one right before
you went up to get that right like know
like the game isn't over I don't do
restart I'm just saying like I might
have started down the path of a save
that I can't use fair enough but I don't
think you did okay I'll say that
it's concerning I would laughed so hard
he came up against like a wall of flames
right now wait didn't you just climb
down that yes but now we're the sub is
at the place now all right I'm not sure
what's going on is this gonna be a boss
fight because I don't have any I didn't
get any of the grenades or anything I
would have told you to get that stuff
you'd be fine oh [ __ ]
a handgun I'd say
also I probably just dodged him do check
on no no pause again go to guys to right
click on it go to auto click that that
should keep it from bursting when you
don't really need it to and you'll say
ma'am oh yeah otherwise you probably
would he use like 12 rounds let me go I
didn't know there was that many and yeah
I think you should be killing them I
agree with us because there are
[Music]
where are you
[Music]
anymore there should be a third she's a
quick turn be impressed that's good so
and now I am searching this area for
goodies puck that looks like a safe but
it's like that
three extra save ease that's a thousand
percent worth it I don't know what this
is should I go in here I don't want to
all right this fish
tap tap tap tap oh now you're tormenting
fish I've earned it
please don't have a bandar snitch what's
going on okay no great because I need to
put the little thingies in there what
about this thing - this piece of
interests I don't really think I know
what's going on here
Oh
oh there's a save in here
I'll take that leaver should I save no
not yet
you'll be right you're not doing
anything like risky yet okay forget him
like what's he doing he's just
constantly hitting buttons that's what I
assume all pilots do on every flight
they're like we'll be taking off in just
a minute
it's a you obviously don't know what was
I suppose we doing I can't leave the
door not that button to be doing I
thought I said I was gonna help oh sorry
that green oh yeah that makes a lot of
sense
the seaplane that's why
[Music]
what am i doing again got that lever I'm
aware I think it's the room previously
we got the ink ribbons is this your
doing you're the fish we have history is
it in here is what doesn't wait on that
box back there
please don't be a snitch
like
what am i doing am i going out here you
just don't have the key to the plane
essentially okay sure these don't have
any banders
[Music]
oh is it this yeah this seems right
doesn't it yes
what there's another way to go back and
that there's another wet there's another
path
yeah back toward the camera I got it I
got it here we go
there's a lift right here right totally
I'm killing it is this okay it's just
something what terrible level design I
feel like I'm going a real long
excursion here a wild goose chase I feel
like that a little bit like here we go
you should not have done that yet really
oh you're living too
well
we're a mine oh my god
how lucky that really worked out you
guys holding out on me oh my god he's
dead
what no way
show yourself what am i doing now got
the key so I'm going back yeah it said k
402 I didn't have like a streamlined way
to get back no I just was like so sure
that oh wait go back go back go back go
back go back go back
I know you you were going the right way
though you missed an item in here oh is
that the fire extinguisher
devices controls that's not an oil
pressure and Academy right there good
job good now we can go back ja I'm so
excited about that box water
go-girl such a San Francisco thing to
care about the environment nothing I
don't
oh it's based in Holland Michigan
actually so nobody cares about the
environment we're in the Michigan on the
Flint home of the carb the Flint tropics
remember uh semi present is it forward
yeah crazy like a lot of things
grandpa works in a Ford plant
oh [ __ ] do I get out of here oh [ __ ]
were you supposed to lower the bridge
again no that would make sense how the
plane get out right that's why I was
like I should be able to get through the
way I can oh that's the gate with the
key right there
okay Faro - let me the [ __ ] out
no bender cease
you know where me no way no way mean
away me
there's another yeah this one you should
use are you serious yeah I don't have an
ink ribbon I'm not kidding
sorry there's I didn't philosophy I put
it away
oh no there's a what am I gonna say box
there just say box in here somewhere
I said why are there no red thingies you
know like why so stingy with the Reds
all right so what would you say I should
be doing right now you say no
save save first whoa Sanford mm-hmm
I do have a name oh wait I do
he's like in the plane like where the
[ __ ] is she I've been pressing the same
six buttons just jack
okay I have saved
you can bind a bow gunpowder with your
crossbow right now let's find out he
just passed it
I'm not even sure if this will work I
think it might need to be the arrow
specifically I mean it yeah
how sweet okay cool those will be good
to have you don't need your night okay
well I'm already on warning so if
anything I should eat ones that I can be
on fine sure right yeah first before you
forget reload your handgun I can't do it
now but I can do it put one of those
herbs away I'll eat one and then I'll
have one okay you don't need the regular
grenades I wouldn't bring those you take
your native launcher for sure so I have
six regs in there bring the bo w rounds
I would just put those in the grenade
launcher right now actually oh my god
what I'm just freaking out and then acid
rounds I'd say oh my god I think that's
good what always we saved anyway we've
got a my back fighting wait for before
you go any farther yeah yeah okay so
reload your handgun okay also put it
back on auto I'd say alright sorry I'm
panicking
okay
eatin herb okay okay put the bo w out in
the grenade launcher okay okay
what should I have a good maybe this guy
grenade launcher okay I'm trying to
think I don't even know if you want
regular grenades I'd put those back and
take the flame ones oh my god I bet you
I you probably won't even need most of
this and I'm probably making some people
cringe because I might be overdoing it
or pick bring their own things but we'll
figure it out
sorry ID like keep hitting your
headphone where I haven't noticed I'm
having a little bit of a panic attack
here alright
is this upon don't bring the flame
grenade just bring the regular ones I'm
so sighs and then we're good to go and
you say about ready right yeah I see
before I did all this work yeah okay
yeah but if we yeah just bring the 12
grenade rounds there's no way you're
gonna need more than that okay you've
got explosive arrows like
can I push these or can I knocks it's a
double can I jump up on here and push
this I'm actually not
a little bit of a mini puzzle here
[Music]
push the left one up and then into the
elevator come around at this side yeah
why do a puzzle in this situation like
why would they put a puzzle in front of
you do you anyway push it towards me
yeah I can't push it very far
oh then go into the elevator no I sorry
I like no that I just thought it got
stopped you all go into the
Oh Lord whose idea was it to ruin the
momentum thereby making me be like yeah
it's not even a good puzzle you know all
right so what I've done it now use the
other doors not you can use it it's
jammed
oh my god
it begins he wasted 15 seconds already
so what 1718 Mary why are you is the guy
pretending he's the girl or is the girl
pretending she's the guy the first
oh my god
it's got Morningstar hands this dr.
Manhattan oh lord please doesn't mean
why even start the timer just yeah it's
just stress makes you tense
oh my god oh my god where is it no where
am I going back back to the submarine
submarine is through the to the right
yes where is he
Oh
God it has what is it how do I kill it
grenades
can I run past it no I cannot all right
let's talk about this
I want caution he pushed me that's it
how about acid rounds or bo bo you try
that
[Music]
wait yeah yeah fast yeah wait wait is
this her yes
now go past him easy what a loser out of
that plane you called that up boss
sorry how am I gonna get the fire
extinguisher they just like it you don't
eat it I know P I think I'm pretty sure
I can double check just to put your mind
at ease but I'm pretty sure if you have
it there you can use it on the fire so
you can back up and have more room to
kill him
but you didn't need eggs you already had
enough family
in real life I'm usually the one that
worries about everything this show is
not indicative of Who I am
get in the sub by the way there yeah
that countdown timer is real does it go
down when I'm in the menu yeah
god this is so stressful I'm just trying
to submarine here and it's still
counting down like how do people do this
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
hey did
this is tense
there's always an alarm and Rudkin these
other games they love it I pushed the
sweet give me in that plane Tim sorry I
guess had the alarm music from the first
resin evil on it's like marathon
playlists like when he ran a marathon he
played it at the end the last mile or so
I don't there's a lot of [ __ ] up there
[Music]
and we're off do we do it I can't
believe we beat the game countdown timer
stop it yay finally over
[Music]
a lien when they found out the alien was
on the spaceship and they weren't really
safe Claire I'm sorry a lot of like
caused a lot of trouble for you
no it's okay it was hard for both of us
remember when you shot your dad
well really hope behind your brother I
know what it's like to be alone
yeah I knew Steve better get used to it
I'm a feeling gonna be alone for a long
time so where should we go now I could
take you anywhere you want to go Clara I
don't think that's how fuel works
[Laughter]
credits
that's how you turn on tanks
Oh bullets
wait is this fight going to the sky
that's pretty nice it would only happen
in a crazy game
no way
way
[Music]
it's like starfox all of a sudden to
beat Vito
thanks a lot the cargo room door I've
set a course for Honolulu should I save
yeah yeah can't hurt you got a bunch of
for anyway so yes what oh I'm just
kidding
[Music]
hey buzz I'm in your pain go I just flew
his jet right into the cargo hold
I'm Chuck give me a push
hate them but I brought you these and me
no that's okay
oh my god why do they just show me his
little bun Oh Lord I'm glad I saved it's
cut no expression at all
what he grew a nail God he's so hot
catapult ready press that button
yes
that should have been run away yeah
make sure he doesn't touch you make sure
you circle
[Music]
no he hit me with his nail rot away all
right he was again should I heal oh yeah
[Music]
also should I change to grenades No
oh he [ __ ] me up hit him a few times
and then go back toward the box he hit
me your mother hill he's gonna Oh Lord
[Music]
what use regular ones don't hit me no
catapult I wonder keeps away he's lined
up with it
Oh
[ __ ] kidding oh wait I forgot to
change my Dodge or hit him once and then
Dodge
nice
oh yeah me run [ __ ] yeah
Oh actually run go back to work attaboy
yes
thank God they kept this planes catapult
died oh my god I don't even know if half
those grenades you shot hit him
I didn't didn't feel like this but he
did it he's dead so if you had not shot
him at all I think it takes like five
catapults Wow that's totally doable but
I don't I think you can save up that
much ammo for the rest the game of just
where's it going this is what happens in
like Starfleet's not really progressive
[Music]
this sounds like the more you know music
but is this day
is he asleep with his eyes open he's
scary and it's explosive choke collar on
yeah what is up with that the lilt of
her nose
alright don't she's asleep
that's a [ __ ] warning stab him
[Laughter]
schemas
just took a weird turn
I feel like they're like trying to show
him as a guy who's evolving as a
character and is now liking her but he
just totally [ __ ] up yeah but she
doesn't know because she was asleep I
know in my book as a third-party viewer
that guy's sucks
yeah he's bit of a creep where are we
latitude where do you okay wait degrees
where do you think they are here the
latitude Alaska no what if it was 82 oh
that's the Antarctic we're over the
Antarctic what that'd be kind of scarier
I thought cold because because she said
Hawaii and I was like it's got to be the
opposite cuz this church
[Music]
now it becomes the thing
good landing
perfect not not
hello save first-half end data does it
cost me another puck I don't think so
also do I need the fire extinguisher you
made separate saves anyway worst comes
to worst we can go I'll go back off the
air and get it and do it all with less
ammo all right oh just kidding I got it
I told you not to worry I'm gonna oh and
I stats you by the way thank you I can't
see it it's totally real thing I like
how the cloud actually looks like it
would be are you jealous
yeah
he actually did not use as much ammo as
you could have wake up Steve did you
kiss me when I was sleeping hopefully
cuz I didn't oh my gosh his little
buckles for bracelets they're so fun
it's like wearing a belt are oh my god
get out of there he's like not letting
go of her she's like get up
thanks he's like I can't trying to
conceal this boner I was weird
Oh planes trashed that was weird
find another way off this oversized
freezer right stop it look away okay
okay let's do it
I feel like I need a jacket I wonder if
I should be going to these places
oof
that's great
oh my god he's dead yeah oh god that
[ __ ] angle that is so Resident Evil
let's give me that angle I knew it they
want you to go over there oh right
I might have [ __ ] up by going over
here I can't there's a lot going on what
should I do
which I leave or should I kill
everything
like if there's more than bullets in
here I should
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
where is he
[Music]
[Music]
okay guys there's I think there's a few
items around here good then it's worth
it raid those lockers girl hey do you
want the bad news or the good news first
I want the bad news the bad news first
you're not gonna be able to get the
Magnum and the boss fight later I'm
gonna be a lot harder but the good news
is you do not need the fire extinguisher
beat the game we we there's a few games
where we didn't do some of that kind of
stuff and we were fine and we've been
really a conservative with stuff so I
know but we like new to get it and we
just like waited so long we couldn't
have done it this episode no we had to
have done it last episode and well if
you want me like in my free time just so
you don't have to replay what you
already play it I I don't want to replay
it I just don't want to get in a point
where we like can't finish the game like
if we need to redo the game I want to do
it now not like in four episodes you
really don't need to it's just gonna be
harder it's just like it's like if you
played do me I'm gonna get all these
magnum rounds and I'm not gonna be able
to use them so you're still gonna get
rounds for everything else it's so
negative I yeah whoa whoa whoa whoa I
elation whoa that's oh [ __ ]
what what did this definitely not a
person this isn't regular murder stuff
from annihilation
oh [ __ ] off
oh right
sorry I didn't realize I could play
should I kill that or like what also am
I do have a Slyke egging me now all
right I just go through I didn't know
that that was happening we what the [ __ ]
I'm see a good cliffhanger what should I
do
I don't want to save what do I do
oh that's poison help no it's not what's
that noise
what what is that heal yourself in like
the next room
what you can heal your poison in like
the next room you mean pass the bug okay
so run it's it's somewhere not in this
room I'm not sure I don't remember this
I just don't feel comfortable saving
when I'm poisoned oh you already came
this is why you came from is it yeah oh
well then it's to the left sorry it's
like now stop putting your left oh my
god it's [ __ ] super gross where is it
all right I'm gonna die how do I know
when I'm gonna die wait didn't I take
the blue herb yeah try it again it might
have counted it twice I'm not sure what
no it's not my inventory I thought I'd
picked up a blue herb used it it's a
planter not up its just use the plans
there again
okay so I'm healed but almost dead yeah
okay now what use an herb just don't
don't get hit by the bug again sprint if
they're gonna there's more gonna be more
mobs just go back to the safe room and
save good weight on oh [ __ ] did he
poison you again you got poison again
what do I do
just go back and do that again but don't
get hit by a bus
there's too many what do you mean don't
know hit you like you just did but heal
up okay so now what save again but don't
get egged don't get a gun and save okay
save again did y'all ready save no oh
okay cool nice I probably should heal
the old then next time well you may have
passed a big fight anyway tell me what
I'm not doing great horse mid-game
resonable bosses ago that one's up there
no yawn is pretty easy once you get the
hang of it in the first game that was
really stressful
the Gators pretty easy into um yeah I'm
Savin sure good shape do you think so
except for the deal oh my god fire more
I'm quitting the shell fire extinguisher
fire extinguish five frames to hold my
bison finger start what's that crazy
restaurant with all the stupid [ __ ] on
the wall
shenanigans waiting no the one with the
cops the one where there's a new one
coming out on 4/20 oh it already came
out there's a new one oh yeah that's a
month ago you talk about super troopers
super troopers - super duper he really
wasn't that good I didn't see them yeah
maybe it was all right got it
all right cool so what'd you think of
the boss fight uh yeah it was so the
first half was like really quick right
like I just basically didn't really get
to see him or anything I just hit him a
bunch of times he was gone but the
second part where I had to like launch a
box out of them was pretty neat mm-hmm I
never died to him so that's shows skill
yeah but I almost died two moths twice
so the mods are a lot scarier
yeah they lay eggs near lay eggs in you
oh no thanks are they poison you I don't
know you both cool we're getting there
so I don't know how far I am in this
game but I think that's except it is
like the halfway point okay well I hope
I don't die thank you you already died
the beginning to subside remember that
didn't really count cuz that was like
your advice I like take out the
Bandersnatch 'as i was just like poor
planning on your part you are holding
the controller but i do the thing that
you say to do okay